y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
llueven las críticas a algunos líderes
mundiales por sus discursos en la
asamblea general de la onu que se
celebra por primera vez de manera
virtual debido al cob y 19 los
mandatarios defendieron sus gestiones
frente a temas claves como el virus el
cambio climático y los derechos humanos
pero muchos usuarios en redes sociales
señalaron lo que llaman mentiras y fake
news en algunas de sus intervenciones en
esta edición analizamos los casos más
notables empezamos es una asamblea
general de las naciones unidas sin
precedentes por primera vez desde su
fundación tras el fin de la segunda
guerra mundial en 1945 los líderes
mundiales no se reúnen de manera
presencial el brote de kobe 19 los
obligó a quedarse en sus países e
interactuar virtualmente para el debate
general al que cada año acuden en
persona a los líderes mundiales se
recomendó a cada orador enviar un vídeo
pregrabado de unos 15 minutos de
duración para ser proyectado en las
pantallas de la sede de la onu en nueva
york de igual manera las reuniones
bilaterales también se están llevando a
cabo en forma remota esta es la primera
vez que se utiliza la tecnología a gran
escala para un evento de tal magnitud
pero en un mundo tan conectado también
ocupa el alcance y la rapidez con las
que viajan las noticias falsas y la
desinformación que diseminan entre otros
los mismos líderes justificando su
gestión
algunos de estos discursos emitidos en
vídeo generaron duras críticas por lo
que varios usuarios calificaron como
afirmaciones abiertamente falsas el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro fue
uno de los focos de las críticas en
redes sociales luego de su discurso ante
el escándalo que ha generado los
incendios en el amazon en la amazonía y
el pantanal que muchos atribuyen a su
desdén por los temas ambientales se
defendió alegando que es víctima de una
campaña internacional de desinformación
y pese a que está comprobado que la
ganadería extensiva la tala y otras
actividades ilegales son grandes
responsables de los incendios
bolsonaro les echó la culpa a los
indígenas y campesinos pobres escuchemos
somos líderes en la conservación de los
bosques tropicales e intensa con teas
impactos incendios ocurren prácticamente
en los mismos lugares al oriente del
bosque donde para sobrevivir brasileño
de ascendencia indígena aquí en más sus
tierras de cultivos en áreas
deforestadas es bien sabido que
bolsonaro es un ferviente escéptico del
cambio climático desde que llegó a la
presidencia en 2019 ha defendido la
minería y la agricultura en reservas
ambiental
de la amazonía que se declarara como
defensor de los bosques no cayó bien
entre los ambientalistas bajo el numeral
checa bozo que podría traducirse como
verificando a bolsonaro usuarios y
organizaciones defensoras del medio
ambiente en brasil se encargaron de
desmentir varias declaraciones de
versionar greenpeace brasil por ejemplo
señaló que en 2019 este fue el país que
más deforestó bosques primarios en el
mundo bajo otro numeral brasil en llamas
o brasil en llamas internet se inundó de
imágenes de la devastación provocada por
el fuego entre ellas troncos ardiendo y
animales muertos o tratando de escapar
vamos a colombia el discurso del
presidente y bando que también fue
motivo de polémica escuchemos por qué
la paz real
en la decisión social de edificar
prosperidad a partir de la verdad de la
solidaridad del apego a la legalidad y
el rechazo contundente a cualquier forma
de violencia hoy en colombia no hay
dilemas entre amigos y enemigos de la
paz las críticas contra el presidente
colombiano estallaron en redes sociales
por parte de legisladores artistas y
activistas bajo el numeral duque
mentiroso y duque mienten la onu
refutaron la intervención del mandatario
habla de paz y en la acción se registran
más de 60 masacres habla de posconflicto
y en la acción acaba con el proceso de
paz dijo un congresista según muchos
defensores del pacto al que llegó el
gobierno de juan manuel santos con la
guerrilla de las farc en septiembre de
2016 el presidente ha mostrado poco
interés en sacar adelante el acuerdo el
partido el centro democrático es uno de
los más grandes detractores las figuras
más importantes de este partido del
presidente permanecieron calladas o sólo
se limitaron a replicar el discurso de
duke otros de sus espacios simpatizantes
políticos destacaron su homenaje a las
víctimas
conflicto y líderes sociales mientras
que opositores al gobierno recordaron
que esta no ha sido la agenda del
mandatario el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador ha sido tal vez uno
de los más cuestionados dentro de su
propio territorio las críticas y las
burlas no se hicieron esperar ante los
comentarios como éste
'hemos
actuado con responsabilidad y a pesar de
la pandemia y de la crisis no hay hambre
en nuestro país su declaración dista de
su proceder inicial cuando el continente
empezaba a registrar sus primeros brotes
de kobe 19 los países vecinos
endurecieron medidas tras ver los
estragos que el virus causaba en europa
pero anglo insistía en promover las
aglomeraciones no dejen
y salir todavía estábamos
en la primera fase ya nosotros yo les
voy a decir cuando no salga fueron más
las críticas que los halagos aunque
éstos también se dejaron ver en internet
tras su discurso en la onu un pequeño
número de sus seguidores lo destacó como
un estadista humanista y patriota
mientras que sus detractores lo
señalaron de negligente y le achacaron
las muertes provocadas por el cob y 19
más de 70.000 fallecidos hasta la fecha
mucho más que rusia colombia y perú que
lo superan en número de contagios a
lópez obrador también le cuestionaron
que dijera que no hay hambre en su país
cuando más de un millón de personas
perdieron sus empleos durante la
pandemia
esto no son los únicos líderes en
cuestión y tampoco es la única vez que
han usado afirmaciones falsas o poco
precisas para promover sus agendas en
redes sociales esta es una de las
situaciones más comunes hasta aquí
revista digital recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra misión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]